moi ce qui m'inquiète beaucoup plus que
le fait qu'ils posent des problèmes à la
droite ce qui est bien dommage ces
dégâts sur la république
c'est finalement une sorte de
putréfaction du débat politique
aujourd'hui qui fait que tous les grands
enjeux importants pour les français
l'emploi la santé
plus généralement un système de sécurité
sociale l'éducation enfin tous ces
thèmes là ne sont plus des battues nulle
part et contre les affaires d'une part
et des campagnes de gérer les lyrics
autistes en tout cas de narcissique
narcissisme extrême d'autre part avec
des candidatures qui sont pas trop ce
qu'elle porte sauf la promotion de soi
le débat politique est vide est absente
cette présence hier et ça c'est très
inquiétant pour la république